here's Anthony Simmonds former first
rounder going against Bruce Brown he
gets that one to go will to Josh I think
that's gonna be a good matchup tonight
and you know once you could commit to
that University it's a place for him you
have a great opportunity to become a
pretty darn good basketball and it's a
16-6 lead now for the Pistons tell you
what when you're guarding the shooter
that can get downhill as well yeah it's
tough tough tough defender here 9 to 14
and it versus one of a good defense
there by Simons good defense and overall
by the Blazers here sign is off to the
races but he misses the dog loses the
handle pistons gone the other way what a
beautiful play there Anthony Simon's
from three
[Music]
[Applause]
Simon's Gary Trent jr. for three he
pulls it and he drains it pulling 2:15
opaque sorry 272 to 90 mins just button
you top on skates yes they pick and roll
as well as drive to the basket but then
he can definitely shoot nice stop - he
is not shy he gets a crack he's gonna go
look because he's gonna look the score
the basketball Simon's back to Robinson
James handles the ball a lot rush knees
the ball a lot there really wouldn't be
a lot of need for Chris Paul
that's actually
[Applause]
here in this first quarter were tuning
to go assignments on fire a little
pennies difficult rate well we got the
father of another day I like it because
the empty sighs I know he was named for
penny but only one is not letting me
down at all and there's the unselfish
past yeah Trent driving step back I'm
gonna take that one but sit inside side
by Jarnell Stokes on the other wing with
three bran 36 Simon's will take another
Ed's hit go through them and get a
bucket
Simon's bangs in another three we're not
even infinite's into this game to be
interesting very interesting you've seen
guys already Oh got it
yeah you never see guys make three in a
row try another Hey when you do you see
it make five in a row don't go to
college go to IMG learn to shoot
you know you've won starving teams one
star yeah surround it with really good
player let me see how about
and a half live guys they had a bunch of
guys who can really play before it's
pretty good by Simons and rebound
secured by Portland
here comes Simon's cutting between two
flipping it up and in 21 for Anthony
Simons good at the trombone for a
semester or two but maybe not for years
[Music]
look like might he got fouled know
called kept alive and Robinson pumps it
down and that's nice play to nice place
by Simons really like he walked on ended
up scoring thirteen hundred points and
led d2 and rebounding in 2016 Robinson
lays it in short Trent the rebound
blasting ahead with Simon's to his left
Pop's it up
Johnson up snow bucket and the rebound
ends up with Simons Simon's through the
lay protein
baking layups is naughty look at this
he's off balance he's floating through
keeps his chin on there we'll see what
he can do for me you may lose a game boy
let's see what he can do
Simon so all this smooth pretty Simon's
now six of six from deep in some Simon's
trilling Simon's cradles it ain't pretty
Simon's with 31 points on 11 of 15
should actually hit you last but they
also see that I slapped your wrist and
that's why it hit you last why should it
be your ball what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content